this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck enjoy this
episode 100% advertisement free if you
would like to support the podcast visit
the minimalists comm slash donate
[Music]
[Laughter]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me hello everybody and
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less less stuff
less clutter less stress and debt and
discontent but a whole lot more meaning
I'm Joshua fields Wilburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode number 8
of the minimalist podcast today we're
going to chat about relationship so
we're gonna do that just in time for
everyone's favorite Hallmark holiday
Valentine's Day but this episode is
obviously applicable to any day of the
year Ryan you have big plans for
Valentine's Day oh man I'm gonna get
Mariah the biggest teddy bear the
biggest box of chocolate no I'm just
kidding um no we don't have we don't
have any Valentine's Day plans
specifically I'll probably get her a
little Valentine's Day card let her know
how much I appreciate her and we don't
really exchange gifts on days like that
we we just went to Florida a few weeks
ago we show each other all year round
how much we love each other and yeah
thanks together when we were on tour for
an entire year I remember how many
postcards you got for her every time we
go to a new city or something and you
didn't wait for like oh it's President's
Day or it's Flag Day here's here's your
special card and you know I took a
lesson from that and I do that all the
time with Becca
now I I I don't wait till Valentine's
Day to give a card that says you know I
care about you it's like hey it's
Wednesday here's a nice reminder that I
care about you I slipped into your bag
before you went to work or something
yeah I think we don't have to wait until
a holiday but sometimes the holiday can
be a reminder for some feature and I
hope you get refocused on the
relationship so today we're going
to answer a bunch of questions about
relationships before we get into our
very first voicemail question let's just
talk about what we mean by it by
relationships when you hear the word
relationship often we think intimate
relationship we think marriage or
partnership or boyfriend/girlfriend but
really there are a bunch of different
types of relationships and so when we
talk about relationships today we'll
obviously talk about that term more
broadly what we'll talk about partners
significant others but we're also gonna
talk about your relationships with your
family and your friends and your
co-workers and your acquaintances
relationships are just the way that we
interact with the other people who are
in our lives so let's go ahead and
listen to our first voicemail this one
is from Alex what is stopping me from
really transitioning into this new life
that I'm I'm trying to find and I'm
specifically concerned about how it's
gonna affect my relationships with
people and my wife because a lot of our
lives revolve around consumption I'm
hesitant to commit to this new lifestyle
as I'm scared or I'm hesitant to to see
how it's gonna affect these
relationships alright Alex thank you for
that voice mail so the first bit of
advice that I would give you is don't
jump up and call yourself a minimalist
you know I think that that would be one
of the worst things you could do it and
we get really excited about something
new oh my gosh I just found this this
minimalist lifestyle and and now I want
to become a middlemost I'm gonna get up
and tell everybody and that's great if
you really feel like you want to do that
but realize that you will get judged you
you will have people who don't
understand and I think the best way to
do it is the way that I did it which was
unintentional but I didn't jump up and
say look at me I'm becoming a minimalist
everyone and you should too no I just
start to simplify my life I started
removing the clutter and the people
around me people at work started saying
things like look at you you you what is
going on you you seem so much less
stress you seem so much calmer you seem
so much nicer
and I can't figure out why and that
opened the door for me to have this
conversation about about simplifying my
life so the cool thing is most people
won't notice the fact that you're
getting rid of some excess stuff the
fact that you're cleaning out the
walk-in closet in your spare bedroom
people don't notice those types of
things even your mother isn't going to
notice that but what they will notice
are the benefits of simplifying your
life yeah if you jump up and call
yourself a minimalist Josh is right
you're certainly going to have people
judge you everything becomes steeped in
irony when you when you say you're a
minimalist especially when you call
yourselves the minimalists but there are
a lot of ways you can incorporate this
deliberate lifestyle into your life with
without doing that I would recommend
that you start to talk to your mother
and friends about having activities that
revolve around experiences rather than
stuff so if the relationships that you
have now if they revolve around stuff
you're going to the mall or you are
giving each other these trinkets you
know maybe you recommend a meal that's
still a way to consume together in a
very meaningful way I have a have a nice
meal prepared for everyone you could go
for walks in the park you can go to a
concert there's a lot of different
experiences that you can incorporate but
yeah if you go to your friends or family
and say alright I'm a minimalist and I
don't want you to give me anything else
period we're gonna start doing
experiences instead of physical items
that is not going to go over well just
start living it and watch how people
react if your relationships are based
around consumption then they're built on
on a fairly shoddy foundation but you
can still do some things that require
you to incorporate material things into
your life we're not against consumption
that's not the problem our problem is
with compulsory consumption and that
bleeds over into our relationships as
well if our relationships happen to be
based on the the bringing of material
things into our life then the question
is what does that relationship really
worth to us what does it mean to us
let's go ahead and move on to our next
voicemail question this one is from
Jill when are you people give me your
thoughts on gift giving and receiving
I'm a huge gift giver I love giving
gifts but I don't like receiving them
back because I don't like clutter I
can't use so how you recommend going
about telling your friends and family
that you don't want to give Jill I would
say that there are different types of
gifts right there are the material
possessions I can hand you a material
possession and say here's this shiny
widget this means I love you or I can
give you something that is more useful
that could be an experience it could
also be a consumable that's not going to
clutter up your life now Jill I'm
actually a lot like you I love giving to
other people but don't necessarily want
to receive that shiny pair of cufflinks
that someone is going to purchase for me
and so I think it's also about setting
that expectation way in advance telling
people and that you yourself love to
give gifts and want to give gifts that
add value but not it's not about
receiving them for you and if they are
going to get you something then maybe
they can gift you an experience maybe
they can gift you some sort of
consumable I love when people buy me
really great coffee and other people
might say I want a bottle of wine or a
wonderful meal and the gift-giving
doesn't have to be relegated to the
giving of physical artifacts yeah I know
for me I have gone and asked friends and
family who typically like to give me
gifts physical items I've asked them to
just spend time with me or to make me
meal I will go out of my way
to ask Mariah's mother um hey for
Christmas you don't have to get me any
gifts just make me some awesome lamb
meatballs and she made these amazing
like lamb meatballs and she still gave
me some gifts which were consumables but
she enjoyed that process a lot more to
write because she knew she was giving
you something you would get immense
value from right how do you really like
absolutely yeah and you know I think
that's that's the best way to give a
gift is just ask someone what they want
or to ask you know
if they need anything and then kind of
base your gifting around that ultimately
that's why you're buying the gift
someone anyway you're trying to make
them happy right and to just pick out a
pair of cufflinks for someone and say
well this is gonna make you happy I mean
that's that's this that's like a really
bad setup for two reasons a the person
receiving the gift may not need that
item at all and then B you're setting
yourself up for this this failure of all
I gave them cufflinks that I haven't
even seen them wear those cufflinks and
you know you're gonna set yourself up
for her feelings when really if a
conversation was had before that that
could all be saved
absolutely Jill I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book essential there's
twelve chapters in there and one of
those chapters is on gift-giving I think
you'll find a lot of value in in that
chapter and hopefully the rest of the
book as well but of course you can re
gift the book once once you're done with
it minimize it find someone else who who
can find value in it once you've had an
opportunity to get value from that book
let's move on to our next question from
Jim I kind of personally came to the
decision that I wanted to simplify my
life and the things I was doing weren't
really making me happy even though they
seemed cool they just really weren't and
at least to me and they can be cool but
it worked in me and the hard part about
this path for me has been doing all this
I have a you know girlfriend at the time
now wife who was really supportive of
this and both of our values align so it
was helpful but I don't have a huge
friend support system that gets why I
found grated you know we're live in
Virginia now nope I work as a painter
run my own business and to them it seems
like I've changed you know necessary for
the better but in my heart and in my
mind I know this works for me Jim your
comment your your question reminds me of
a few things one is first of all I would
define relationships this way and I'm
gonna send you a copy of our very first
book called minimalism love a meaningful
life there's an entire chapter on
relationships in that book and what we
attempted to do it with that book is
identified
and define the the three different types
of relationship so first we have your
primary relationship so those would be
the people generally you can you can
count them on one hand two hands if you
grew up in a Catholic family those would
be your people close to you your
significant other maybe your children
your your closest friends a handful of
your primary relationships the people
who are truly closest to you and then
you have your secondary relationships
people you still love people you really
care about extended family and people
you've known for a long time who share
similar values as you and then you have
on the the third tier you have your
people on the periphery and those could
be co-workers acquaintances networking
buddies bosses employees people you've
known for a while but maybe you've
drifted apart and I think it's important
to realize that over time those tiers
will change and sometimes we have to
reprioritize those those tiers as well I
know in my life when I was back in the
corporate world my people in the primary
tier didn't actually get much of my time
because I was spent all my time on
people in the periphery with coworkers
and bosses and networking events and
it's not that those people were
inherently bad or wrong it was bad to
spend time with them but you have only
24 hours in the day
and so we have to find ways to
reallocate our time to the people who
matter most and Jim your comment there
really made me think of a quote from
epictetus those who pursue the higher
life of wisdom who seek to live by
spiritual principles must be prepared to
be laughed at and condemned many people
who have progressively lowered their
personal standards and an attempt to win
social acceptance and life's comforts
bitterly resent those a philosophical
bent who refuse to compromise their
spiritual ideals and who seek to better
themselves never live your life in
reaction to these diminished souls be
compassionate toward them and at the
same time hold to what you know is good
when you begin your program of progress
chances are the people closest to you
will divide you or accuse you of
arrogance it is your job to comport
yourself humbly and to consistently hew
to your moral ideals cling to what you
know and your heart is best then if you
are steadfast the very people who
ridiculed you will come to admire you if
you allow the mean-spirited opinions of
others to make you waver in your purpose
you incur a double shame how long ago
was that written about 2,500 years ago I
believe crazy that is so crazy because
it's the truth it's when you when you
start living this lifestyle
yeah the primary people in your life
totally start I don't wanna say judging
maybe not judging you as much as judging
themselves because that's certainly what
it can feel like a lot of the time if
trouble understand it yeah when when you
know when you go to someone and say I'm
gonna live more deliberately I'm trying
to simplify my life all of a sudden
people start to feel judged like Oh
should I start simplifying my life I
start living more deliberately is this
an attack on my lifestyle right and
eventually once they see how minimalism
is not this crazy stoic lifestyle that
we're reading from Stoics right now
behind but minimalism is certainly not
about being a stoic and once they see
that they do circle back around I can't
tell you how many friends that left not
left but maybe just lost contact with
and then after a year - of living this
lifestyle in them I'm seeing it kind of
came back around reached back out to me
and the ones that were kind of skeptical
were then saying oh I could see where
this minimalism thing actually could
benefit my life and sometimes it does
take a couple years for those friends to
come around but but certainly the ones
that that do love you and and can see
the benefits will will have a good
chance of coming around at least I was
gonna say to Jim to you know you need to
find supportive friends I don't know how
else to put that I'm not saying that you
need to get rid of the friends that you
have now but go find yourself some
supportive people and people used to ask
us
on tour all the time how can we find
supportive people who are living these
simple lives who are applying this
deliberate lifestyle and we never really
had an answer to that until we started
minimalist org which I know we've
mentioned on this show before but there
are a hundred cities across the world
where groups get together and they
support each other on their minimalist
journeys they don't there's no judgment
there it's not a competition of who has
the least stuff it's just a supportive
group of people who are there to help so
that's that's somewhere you could
certainly go also you can go to
meetup.com there are a ton of different
groups that get together there that even
if it's not about minimalism just find
some common interests that you can that
you can share with people and find some
supportive people because I mean we are
who we hang out with and if you're if
you're hanging out with people who
aren't supporting you I can only imagine
what that is what that's doing to you
Jim think God do you have a wife that's
supportive that's that is key that is
awesome yeah I think it's great and and
if you're looking for maybe a more
challenging side of things we wrote an
essay called
letting go of shitty relationships and
I'll let you take a look at that if you
just go to the minimalists comm slash
relationships we'll put a link to it in
the show notes as well Jim thanks your
question let's move on to another
question from Kaye what you say in
relationships there's a point where
minimalism ends and kind of negligence
begins you know there's being
minimalistic about something and then
there's not putting enough effort in
okay when I hear your question what I
hear is is there a time when you take
minimalism too far and and that
negatively affects your relationship
because you feel like you're being
negligent because of maybe lack of
things or a lack of sharing possessions
a lack of something in your relationship
and what I would say is that minimalism
is actually the opposite of negligence
minimalism is you said it's about
experiences and that's part of
minimalism is about intention and
what it allows us to do is get the
excess out of the way the the excess
stuff but the the excess distractions
and focus on what's truly important be
intentional about what's important and
the most important things in our life
aren't things at all it's a cliche but
it ends up being true and one of the
most important things in our lives or
our relationships with other people so
minimalism allows us to focus on those
relationships in a way that is more
deliberate in a way that is more
intentional in a way that will actually
improve your relationships and not allow
you to neglect those relationships yeah
I mean I'm constantly asking myself what
is the last thing I've done or when's
the last time I've showed Mariah that I
love her and that I appreciate her and I
feel like I do this every day whether
it's with a goodbye kiss in the morning
or whether it's with you know cooking
cooking us a meal at night but I am
constantly asking that question when is
the last time I showed Mariah that I
appreciate her and I and I think that's
something that everyone can ask
themselves as you when's the last time I
showed my partner that I love them and
that that certainly will help people
live more deliberately like it's a great
question you in the the way to be more
intentional is to start to ask better
that are quite questions in my life and
am i showing this person that I care
about them or how can I show them that I
care about them more and and intention
is really the bedrock of of living a
more meaningful life and that starts
with the questions we're asking if you
want a better outcome I strongly
recommend asking better questions okay
we have a whole chapter on on
relationships in our our book essential
and I'd love to send you a copy of that
as well thank you for your question
let's move on to one last voicemail here
this one is from Kelsey well I'm not
very concerned with other people's
opinions of my choices I would love to
be able to give better responses when
people who don't know a lot about
minimalism consider it just some
ridiculous lifestyle sad and kind of
brushed off so do you have any
suggestions on how to do that
I think it really depends on how open
your friends are to to the concept you
know we have a friend of ours Dan Harris
who wrote a book called 10% happier it's
about meditation and mindfulness and
where that title comes from I've
actually borrowed it a few times to
explain a bunch of different things but
he started meditating he didn't expect
that he would be living the sort of
meditative life and this was back in in
the 2000s went before meditation was
really in vogue and it was still thought
of his rather woowoo and pseudoscience
and and a little strange to a lot of
people and so when people asked him oh
you're one of those meditators why are
you doing that and he couldn't find a
good answer and eventually one day one
of his close friends asked him why he
was meditating and he just blurted out
it makes me ten percent happier and he
just saw the features change in that
person's face because that was something
that seemed totally attainable it wasn't
about like it totally changed my life
and everything's different now and I can
see in vivid colors that you can't see
and all of these other things it was
about you know what I'm a little bit
happier with this and I think minimalism
sort of the same thing you know
minimalism is a way to make you
appreciably happier but at first it's
like okay how can I become a little bit
happier well the way that I became a
little bit happier was I removed a lot
of the clutter from my life which helped
me remove a lot of the stress and the
overwhelm and eventually helped me to
remove a lot of debt from my life and so
explaining those types of benefits as
minimalism is a way to make me happier
I've been able to eliminate some debt
and some clutter from my life these
things that people look forward to doing
themselves a lot of people want to get
out of that a lot of people want to live
a less clutter life a lot of people want
to have fewer distractions in their life
and if you have friends who are really
open to a dialogue about this then maybe
give them
a book about it and I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
which is my personal favorite of what
we've written and it's a whole story
about going from an unintentional life
to a much more intentional life and the
important thing to to kind of
communicate so your friends and family
is that this is not there's no endgame
with this this is not like a 30 day 30
step process this is a lifelong process
it is it's about for one person it might
be about getting out of debt but then
it's also about staying out of debt
another person might be getting that
closet decluttered but then it's keeping
in that closet declutter so minimalism
is not this thing that you can just
bring into your life and then it fixes
everything and then you can ignore it
it's something that that we have to
constantly constantly be incorporating
into our life yeah we'd love to hear
what you all have to say so if you have
a comment about relationships whether
that's intimate relationships or
friendships or anything in between
including minimalism tips for how you
handle your relationships then leave us
a voicemail 406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 or air
our favorite comments and tips on the
next episode and if your voicemail is
selected we'll send you an autographed
copy of one of our books either
essential or minimalism love a
meaningful life or my favorite
everything that remains we had a
question recently on with a hashtag asks
the minimalist question on social media
and someone asks like what's the
difference between your three books like
you just wrote three books about
minimalism and like we just put a
different cover on the same book or
something and man that's a genius idea
no we in fact we very intentionally put
together three different books because
they cover three different aspects yeah
this is an overly simplistic explanation
but I like to say that one of them is
why to book one of them is a what to
book and one of them is a how-to book so
the why to the the perp
behind minimalism the whole story behind
minimalism is our book called everything
that remains and it's our most popular
book and a lot of people read a lot of
people with found value in it and and
you can probably find that at your local
library or you can ask them for it and
they can they can get a copy ordered for
you the what to book is our first book
which is called minimalism live a
meaningful life and that book really
covers the the five values that we
uncovered with minimalism health
relationships passion growth
contribution and how you can focus on
living a more meaningful life by getting
the excess out of the way and focusing
on on those five areas every day and
then our essay collection is a book
called essential and that's a hundred
and fifty different essays about living
a more intentional life but it breaks it
down into these twelve different areas
of living more intentionally so it
starts with minimalism and the stuff but
then it goes into other areas of life
like finances and mindfulness and how do
you define success and so we try to look
at those twelve different areas of life
of living a more intentional life and
provide those to you how you can do that
in a more of a how-to book and so you're
welcome to check out any of those at
your local library
or if you decide to buy a copy make sure
that you minimize it afterward find a
friend or family member who's willing to
get some value from it once you're done
get value from or if your library
doesn't have a copy give it to them they
guess certainly use it absolutely okay
let's move on to our itunes comment of
the week this one kind of cracked me up
the title of this comment is born again
Jamie ray 21 21 I am a born again
minimalist I discovered this great
podcast after an argument with my
husband an argument fueled by our
excessive possessions regarding the
tidiness or lack thereof of our home as
I desperately searched for answers I
discovered the minimalistic parrot
and out of the ashes I was a born-again
minimalist we now embark on a 30-day
journey to rid ourselves of the
excessive the unnecessary and the
superfluous things in our lives which we
have acquired during our time together
in order to live more intentionally with
each other and those things which either
serve us a purpose or bring us joy thank
you for inspiring this new adventure I
thought that was pretty appropriate for
the relationships hallelujah that we
have now that is that is really cool I'm
really glad when I hear stories like
that I know we've had other comments
from other readers at tour stops where
they've like Maine you guys totally
helped our marriage out and like that is
that's like one of the biggest
compliments I think someone can give you
but that's interesting how the 30-day
minimalism game is what is helping them
kind of bring bring their relationship
closer together and get on the same page
when it comes to all the clutter in
their homes well thank you very much
Jamie ray 2121 really appreciate it yeah
thanks Jamie ray well we'll send you a
copy of everything that remains as well
thanks for the awesome comment and thank
you to everyone else who has left us a
review on iTunes yeah you're positive
honest reviews helped our simple living
message reach more ears so man please
keep them coming we'll continue to read
our favorite iTunes comments on the
podcast so feel free to get extra
creative with with your comments okay
now let's move on to our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round
we call it the the rapid-fire round I'm
Shawn the edited in a bunch of lightning
which was awesome so we'll call it the
the rapid-fire round we put in like a
machine gun noise or something alright
time for the rapid-fire round one toe
[Laughter]
keep the change ya filthy animal
this is where we answer questions from
social media we're on Twitter and
Instagram the minimalists and
facebook.com slash the minimalists our
first question is from ana and asks how
do I bring minimalism into my
relationship if my husband isn't ready
that's a very good question you know
this question made me think of Joshua
Becker's new book that is getting ready
to come out it's called the more of less
and there's a chapter in there called
partners unless and I'm just gonna read
a few paragraphs from this so you guys
are getting a little taste of this
before it's officially out when does
that come out March 3rd I believe it's
less whole story about Ryan in the book
as well people who choose minimalism as
a lifestyle may face any number of
doubters these could be friends
colleagues or parents but what do you do
when the biggest doubter of all is
usually your biggest supporter what
happens next when your partner doesn't
support the new you the fact that you
live together only complicates the issue
after all you share living space and so
does your stuff first talk explain what
minimalism is and why it attracts you
share this book with your partner
describe your vision for how minimalism
can be good for the two of you make it
clear that you are encouraging
minimalism not as an attack on or
criticism of the other but because you
love your partner and think minimalism
will be good for him or her to then
listen to what your partner has to say
in return be careful about when and how
you initiate this conversation too often
our conversations about clutter arise
from frustration so they manifest
themselves as attacks on other people
the moment when you are upset that a
closet is too full or a drawer won't
shut is not the right time instead find
a quiet moment when you were drinking
coffee or eating dinner to share
you have been learning and how you think
it would benefit your home always focus
on the benefits and the positive changes
that could come from it and remember the
minimalism conversation is really not
one conversation at all it's almost
always many conversations so if your
partner seems resistant keep talking
about it in calm reasoned manner after
you clear up some misunderstandings and
work out some differences you may find
that your partner begins to catch the
vision in the meantime resist the
temptation to remove your partner's
belongings without permission start with
your own stuff and minimize as much as
you can without treading on shared
territory you may be surprised how much
clutter you can remove from your home
just by getting rid of your own things
your actions to simplify your
possessions are not a workaround to try
to initiate minimalism a defense of your
partner rather they are another way of
presenting the benefits of minimalism
actions speak louder than words so allow
the benefits of your clutter free life
to do their own convincing a clean
clutter free side of your shared closet
will be more convincing than an
explanation of the 80/20 principle a
refreshingly stress-free desktop or
nightstand will begin to look attractive
to your partner the first time he or she
misplaces something important I think
the biggest takeaway from from that
little excerpt is to not force your
partner into doing anything yes so
really to really show by example and
anytime you bring up minimalism anytime
you bring up deliberate living
simplicity whatever you want to call it
bring it up in a way that is kind and
loving and not accusatory
I mean certainly Josh didn't come to me
and say hey Ryan you have way too much
stuff in your life you're really
overweight and minimalism can help you
lose some weight and get rid of this
stuff and can help you get rid of debt
if he approached me that way I would
have probably been like okay thanks
thanks for the criticism jerk
yeah that's why the why to portion is so
much more important as Joshua Becker
outlined there it's don't explain how to
how to clean out your claws that are
here's the 80/20 rule because the how-to
stuff is boring and it comes off as
accusatory as you said and if we explain
the the why to the purpose that's when
people latch on to the benefits and then
the how-to stuff follows pretty quickly
yeah and I couldn't agree more with the
action speaks louder than words the only
way that why shouldn't say the only way
but one of the best ways to get your
partner to see the benefits is to see it
in you and to see how how you are living
a more meaningful life that is really
what's gonna drive them to to jump on
board for sure next question yeah let's
move on to I think we have one from Ali
what can I do when I feel I don't love
anymore Ali I'll tell you this
sometimes love lasts a lifetime and
sometimes love is just a season and
seasons change over time and we
shouldn't try to latch on to a
springtime when summer has arrived it
just doesn't work that way and so
sometimes we have to be willing to to
walk away and so I'm going to read an
excerpt from an essay that I wrote a
while ago it's one of the favorite
things that that that I've ever written
it's called the things we are prepared
to walk away from what are you prepared
to walk away from this often unasked
question shapes one of the most
important principles of my life we are
all familiar with the age-old
theoretical situation in which our home
is burning and we must grab only the
things that are most important to us of
course most of us would not dash into
the inferno and reach for material
things first
we'd ensure the safety of our loved ones
and pets then once they're safe we grab
only the irreplaceable things photo
albums computer hard drives family
heirlooms everything else would be lost
in the conflagration I tend to look at
this situation at a differently though
taking the hypothetical a bit farther
there is a scene in the movie heat in
which neo McCully Rob
De Niro's character says allow nothing
in your life that you cannot walk out on
in 30 seconds flat although my life
isn't anything like McCulley's he's the
movies bad guy I share this sentiment
almost everything I bring into my life
material possessions ideas habits and
yes even relationships I must be able to
walk away from at a moment's notice many
of you will disagree with me because
this ideology might sound crass or
insensitive but I'd like to posit to you
that it is actually the opposite our
preparedness to walk away is the
ultimate form of caring if I purchase
new possessions I need to make certain I
don't assign them too much meaning being
able to walk away means I won't ever get
too attached to my belongings and being
unattached to stuff makes our lives
tremendously flexible filled with
opportunity if I take on a new idea or
have it I do so because it has the
potential to add value to my life
new ideas shape the future me same goes
for new habits over time my ideas change
improve and expand and my current habits
get replaced by new habits that continue
to help me grow our readiness to walk
away from ideas or habits means we're
willing to grow we're willing to
constantly pursue a better version of
ourselves and if I bring a new
relationship into my world I know that I
must earn their love respect and
kindness
I also expect they too are willing to
walk away should I not provide the
support and understanding that they
require this means we must both work
hard to contribute to the relationship
we must communicate and remain cognizant
of each other's needs and above all we
must care these fundaments love
understanding caring communication these
fundaments build trust which builds
stronger relationships
in the long run it sounds paradoxical
but our willingness to walk away
actually strengthens our bond with
others and the opposite stance being
chained by obligation to a relationship
is disingenuous a false loyalty birthed
from pious placation there are obvious
exceptions to this rule there are
certain things we cannot easily walk
away from a marriage a business
partnership a job that pays the rent a
passion the key is to have as few
exceptions as possible naturally even
these exceptions aren't exceptions for
everyone
marriages often end as new businesses
people get laid off and passions change
over time even though we might not be
able to walk away from these things in
quote 30 seconds flat we can ultimately
walk away when these situations no
longer add value to our lives or worse
when they drain value from our lives
everything I allow into my life enters
it deliberately if my home was a flame
there's nothing I own that can't be
replaced all my photos are scanned all
my important files are backed up and all
my stuff has no real meaning similarly
I'm prepared to walk away from nearly
anything even our website or my writing
class or writing in general if need be
doing so safeguards my continued growth
and improves my relationships with
others both of which contribute to a
fulfilling life a life of meaning it was
CS Lewis who fifty years ago
eloquently said don't let your happiness
depend on something you may lose in
today's material world a world of fear
fueled claim his words seemed more
apropos than ever
we're not promulgating people to just
walk away from from something that
they're unhappy with I mean certainly in
in Ali's case here do everything you can
to to fix the relationship try to give
as much as you can
until you feel like you can't give any
more in that and that's really where
where I look at when I need to walk away
from something how much have I given to
it have I have I given enough have I
given too much is it exhausting me and
I'm not getting anything back those are
those are definitely can help sort those
feelings out and relationships change
over time and just because you had a
phenomenal intimate relationship in the
the spring of love you move on to the
summer of the fall the winter it doesn't
mean that you have to completely ditch
the relationship and walk away from it
completely you may walk away from the
circumstance in which you're in I have
intimate relationships that I've been in
where I have people who are still really
great friends we may not have the
intimate part of a relationship we still
have a phenomenal relationship otherwise
and I think it's you're able to keep
that in mind you're able to set up a
relationship however you want it to be
as long as both parties can can agree to
that all right our next question is from
Nadine ideas for a minimalist date I was
trying to think of what a non minimalist
date would be like going out and buying
a Lexus or something I have no idea I
mean dates are usually pretty simple to
begin with and I know for me when I was
dating it was always like a walk in the
park there's some amazing parks and and
some trails around here in Missoula to
walk through there's a great coffee
places just having a cup of coffee is
nice yeah just any anything simple like
that what do you do for your simple
dates you know a couple things one is
Nadine the question I would ask is
when's the last time you watch the
sunset with someone as cliche as that
sounds it's really awesome when you
actually do it in terms of first dates I
tend not to do first dates I learned
this from our friend Colin right the the
first date sort of paradigm there's
there's so much built-up into the first
date and so having coffee with someone
first without any of the implied
expectations or standards that are set
by the first date you're able to get to
know a person and having coffee with
someone allows you to walk away from
that after 1530 minutes or if it's going
really well and you've spent the last
two or three hours together I could say
my
non first date first date with with
Becca was was a coffee date and it was
just meeting for coffee right after
lunchtime and it ended up you know being
several hours of just talking and it was
it was awesome and that led to other
stuff but there wasn't that same
expectation in there so a minimal estate
try to go in there with as few
expectations as possible mhm if you want
to share an amazing experience go look
at a sunset our next question comes from
Christopher what are your thoughts on
the relevance of engagement rings do you
need one in this day and age just like
any other possession do they add value
and what a loaded question yeah well the
first thing right when I hear oh I think
of engagement ring the first thing I
think of is blood diamonds so you look
it mean there are there's so many kids
who's insane who have their arms cut off
in Angola or the Congo or Zimbabwe
Liberia Sierra Leone and we don't think
of the true cost of these diamonds even
though there's this you were supposed to
spend three months of your of your
salary on which is absurd it's literally
a rock and Neil deGrasse Tyson has this
great bit so you know that they're able
to now create real diamonds using
science to carbon basically and they're
able to create real not not cubic
zirconia is not fake diamonds they're
able to create real diamonds that are
far more flawless than then the diamonds
that we extract from the earth the
problem is that people don't quote want
them because they're not quote real
diamonds but they are actually real
diamonds we're able to to to produce
them and so it's a very strange thing
that we've gone way out of a way to give
meaning to a rock this rock is more
meaningful and and I'm reminded of
another essay that we wrote called the
commodification of love and so if it's
okay with y'all I'm gonna read a quick
snippet from from that it's so much
shorter essay here
there's always another hollow holiday
lurking somewhere around the corner
Valentine's Day Mother's Day sweetest
day birthdays Christmas we've programmed
ourselves to give and receive gifts on
these and many other holidays to show
our love for one another and obviously
an engagement would fall under that as
well we've been told that gift-giving is
quote one of our love languages well
this is ridiculous and yet we treat it
as gospel I love you see here's this
expensive shiny thing that I bought for
you
gift-giving is not a love language any
more than Pig Latin is a Romance
language rather gift-giving is a
destructive cultural imperative in our
society and we've bought it literally
hook line and sinker we've become
consumers of love the grotesque idea
that we can somehow commodify love is
knotting we often give gifts to show our
love because we are troubled by real
love buying diamonds is not evidence of
everlasting devotion commitment trust
understanding these are indications of
devotion gift-giving is by definition
transactional but love is not a
transaction love is transcendent it
transcends language and material
possessions and can be shown only by our
thoughts actions and intentions
perhaps Jonathan Franzen said it best
love is about bottomless empathy borne
out of the hearts revelation that
another person is every bit as real as
you are to love a specific person and to
identify with his or her struggles and
Joy's as if they were your own you have
to surrender some of yourself this
doesn't mean that there's something
necessarily wrong with buying a gift for
someone but don't fool yourself by
associating that gift with love love
doesn't work that way I think when it
comes to engagement ring
is it's completely respectable it's what
are the reasons behind it is it to just
show someone hey I love you I put a you
know car on your finger I'm not going to
name names or anything to protect the
innocent but I was just at a wedding
last year at a certain point where I
remember the bride having this you know
amazing day when she got this engagement
ring it was all over Facebook mm-hmm and
then I remember by the end of the
wedding we were talking and she can't
believe how much debt she went into that
her her partner went into to get that
engagement ring and how it wasn't giving
her the same emotion that it was just a
year prior to the wedding so that again
it just goes back to the reason behind
getting that ring if it's just to keep
up with the Joneses and to you think
it's going to show someone that you love
them that's you know that's probably not
the best reason you get an engagement
ring
yeah we're not judging anyone here if
you want a ring or you want something to
to signify your your love for someone
yeah I think of I was listening to
there's a hip-hop artist called his
name's Kevin gates and he someone was
interviewing him while he was being
interviewed on The Breakfast Club and
they asked him why don't you wear your
your wedding ring and he said I do I
wear my wedding ring in my heart and it
was like to me that the best answer and
what he was saying is you know I show my
love through my actions and there's
nothing I hide nothing I keep from from
my wife and I love her and I show her
that every day and I don't need a
wedding ring to prove that to to someone
externally now if you want a ring
because you feel that it signifies
something then I would say make sure you
consume one with intention and be very
very careful to not purchase a diamond
that a kid lost his arm for okay our
next question is from Sachi how do you
determine whether a relationship adds
value to your life when I read this
question the first thing I thought about
was this Tony
eivin's quote he says some of the
biggest challenges and relationships
come from the fact that most people
enter a relationship in order to get
something they're trying to find someone
who's going to make them feel good in
reality the only way a relationship will
last is if you see a relationship as a
place that you go to give and not a
place that you go to take so I think the
first question if I was Sachi that I
would ask myself is how much value am i
adding to this relationship because
that's where it really starts there
right it starts with how much we're
putting into it if you're at a point
where you feel like you're putting a lot
into a relationship and you're getting
nothing back where you are being taken
from and not giving back to it all that
is that certainly is a problem and that
is something that that should definitely
be looked at for me in those situations
it's a matter of okay is this
relationship is this a net negative or a
net positive for me how am I feeling
most of the time how is this person
making me feel most of the time am I
constantly letting this person down or
is this person constantly berating me
with you know arguments or nagging or
whatever it may be those are certainly
questions asked but I think it starts
with yourself I agree I think every
relationship whether it's a friendship
or a romantic relationship or or
somewhere in between some other type of
relationship every relationship is a
series of gives and takes and so it's
not just what I decide in my life but
what am I able to add value to myself
the way I look at as every relationship
has an sbox in the middle and I've
learned this the hard way in the past
where I think in order for a
relationship to work both people must
contribute to it and get something from
that us box that says this hypothetical
us box in the middle of the relationship
you don't just give and you don't just
get from a relationship if you if you
just if you're just giving you're going
to feel used you're gonna feel exploited
you're gonna feel
taken advantage of and if you only take
from the relationship well then by
definition you're a parasite you're a
freeloader
you are a bottom feeder in that
relationship and and the way to balance
that out is to give whatever you can and
doesn't mean that every relationship is
is equally there's not 50/50 I'm going
to give this amount of love and you're
going to give me the equal amount of
love I'm gonna give you the same amount
of respect and I expect the same exact
amount of respect no you give what you
can give whether that's a resource like
money or time or it's caring it's
understanding it's it's love it's
compassion you give what you can
and you take what you need where I've
gone wrong in the past I have not given
as much as I could and I've taken too
much I've taken more than I need or I've
just taken how much I need but not given
to the relationship at all and I've
become that parasite that I am afraid of
becoming and so I've learned that lesson
in the past and so yeah Saachi if you
were to rephrase the question
you would say how do I determine whether
I can add value to a relationship I just
want to add one more point whenever we
into a relationship and we start keeping
track of what the other person has done
wrong yes it is a zero-sum game you if
you start out so let's say that Josh and
i's relationship we start out at this
this level of a hundred and Josh comes
in and I was really hoping that he would
give me a hug but instead he just sat
down and he you know he's having a bad
morning didn't give me a hug and then
all a sudden keeping track of that now
I'm at ninety nine and then during the
podcast I start biting my nails and then
Josh you know all of a sudden my bucket
gets moved down to ninety nine and then
when he does something good for me I
forget to put that back in there I just
I just keep track of all the bad stuff
and that will ultimately just bring you
down to a zero-sum game and and I think
that's why my relationships are so much
better now over these last five or six
years is because I don't keep track I
don't sit there and think to myself okay
Josh hasn't done this which I really
wanted him to do and he did this that I
really didn't want him to do
Monteux you anything or any of those
experiences it's more about again what
can I give the relationship what do I
need to change to to make it a better
relationship or to keep it a good
relationship you're you're a great
example that you you don't hold grudges
you don't hold things against people
you're still willing to walk away if
it's bad if someone spits in your face
you're not gonna be like oh that was Wow
he spit on my face thanks you you're
going to be willing to walk away but at
the same time you're not gonna hold it
against someone that you really care
about because you realize that caring
means accepting the other person for all
their flaws and like you said those
flaws are glaring so you can hold it
against someone and because the flaws
are much easier to see you then then you
know the the beauty marks yeah all right
our next question from will want to
spend time with good friends however all
they ever do is hang out at the mall
well I got to tell you find some of your
friends again not meaning to get rid of
your current friends but find friends
who want to do things besides hang out
at the mall we the the world we live in
now we have so many different tools you
have to help us meet new people yeah
it's not a matter of just going out to a
bar or some public place and meeting
people there are there's minimalist org
which we talked about earlier meetup
comm which I talked about earlier
weather has been a great resource for
man I've met a lot of my closest friends
on on Twitter I know that sounds crazy
to a lot of people but you tend to be
able to connect with people with similar
values I know I'll just add one thing
real quick for for well you know I tend
to say that you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you I mean you can surround
yourself with supportive people I've had
some people criticize that in the past
and say wasn't that treating
relationships in a transactional way by
changing the people around you surround
yourself with different people and
letting go of the other relationships
it's not necessarily letting go the
other ones it's reprioritizing your time
and will said that you know these are
good friends however all they want to do
is hang out at the mall are they really
good friends if they will only hang out
with you at the mall
doesn't sound like they share similar
values as you and there's nothing wrong
with going and buying something
especially if you're doing so
responsibly and and and deliberately but
you might want to ask ask them if
they're willing have you have you ever
tried we'll just say are you willing to
meet me here instead and quite often
you'll see that they've just been
meeting at the mall based on momentum
maybe that's because that's what we've
always done and if you say hey would you
be willing to make meet me at the rock
climbing gym they might say oh yeah that
sounds like fun and and so you can try
to change that pattern without simply
just walking away from them if you've
done everything you can and you feel
like okay I don't actually say share the
same values with these people it doesn't
mean they're bad or wrong but you can
find new supportive people in your life
I would also recommend an essay on our
website it's called goodbye fake friends
so if you've done everything and you
feel like you still have to walk away
from people who are not good friends at
the end of the day there's an essay
there called goodbye fake friends it's
at the minimalists comm slash fate all
right our our next question is from Omar
if both parties have dreams goals to
pursue that are impossible for both to
be done simultaneously what advice would
you give I would say a couple things one
is you have goals that aren't mutually
exclusive meaning or if you have goals
that you just that are mutually
exclusive but they just mean to be done
at different times then take turns and
be supportive of the other person's
goals often you'll find that even though
you have different goals you can get
there together by being supportive
sometimes you might have goals that are
to counteract each other and then you're
gonna have to ask some more difficult
questions about the relationship as a
whole am i growing in a different
direction from this person because they
want to have six kids and I never wanted
to have children well wait a minute
that's a goal that you can't take turns
on there but if you have goals that are
just slightly different and you can take
turns well then let them go first and
pursue that goal if you plan on being
together for a while you can
switch
on and off and that level of support
will allow you to grow together alright
our next question is from corn Ellie how
to engage your loved ones in a fun way
into minimalism lifestyle man I think
the first thing I think of is the 30-day
minimalism game I see a ton of people
online having fun with that
so the minimalism game works like this
you find a friend or a family member who
wants to get rid of some of their stuff
or an enemy or an enemy and you start on
the first day of the month where you get
rid of one thing on the second day of
the month you get rid of two things
third day of the month three things so
forth and so on basically whoever lasts
the longest wins and whatever you guys
bet is up to you you get bet a meal or
you know someone has to wear a dress out
in public or something whoever loses but
but yeah it's it's a great way to get
people involved and to kind of have some
fun with it I know another thing that
Josh and I have done too I'm thinking
about um the soup kitchen we did in
Vancouver that was a lot of fun yeah I
mean you can find ways to contribute to
your community whether that's a food
bank soup kitchen it's a shelter it's
like you're sitting there you're working
but it's like the most fun work I've
ever done because it's like this
volunteer aspect you're not getting paid
for it there is no boss that's gonna
come down on you for not stocking the
cans right or asking questions and
helping the register so it's it's a way
to to kind of give back and have fun at
the same time
yeah Habitat for Humanity is a good one
to also you know what I will add in one
more thing the donation box I kind of
talked about this on our last episode
but having kids put in that donation box
I've seen a lot of kids that kids just
love to help in general even if it's
like recycling if you can if you can get
a kid excited I'm sorry you can get a
child excited about helping and you can
do that with helping with recycling or
donating or whatever it may be so gather
a few ideas alright our next question is
from Alexandria how do you get a spouse
to understand the idea of living in the
moment I try and make rules up like no
phones at the breakfast table or I talk
about slowing down and enjoying the
moment
but it seems like my approach just isn't
working and I come off as a nag my
husband is always in a rush to get to
the next thing get things done on the
to-do list Alexandre it's because you're
being a nag you know there are no rules
in love and and by setting up rules we
are setting up ourselves for failure
because rules are just a list of
expectations basically well I think too
if you go to your spouse and you say hey
this is how you're gonna act from here
on out there are our rules I mean that
is definitely not the way to get
someone's buy-in that's what you have to
do I have to get there to find ways to
get there by oh yeah so sure so going to
your partner and explained it very much
what Joshua Beck Joshua Becker was
talking about going to your partner
they're very loving
a very kind way and explaining how these
these ideas applied to your life are
going to help the relationship that's
that's what's going to start to win them
over and then maybe you say something
like we sure do use our phones a lot at
the breakfast table what do you think
about us maybe trying to talk to each
other and engage more instead of having
our phones at the table five words that
have changed my conversations are would
you be willing to and then whatever it
goes after that the blank would you be
willing to blank and asking them in a
way letting them know that it's
something that you care about it's not a
rule you're setting up you're asking
them for their buy-in it's accomplishing
the same thing as saying hey we're not
gonna have phones at the breakfast table
anymore that would be like if if this
guy were to come around say hey how come
you don't have a to-do list like I have
a to-do list here is our to-do list that
wouldn't that wouldn't work nearly as
well as hey would you be willing to do
these few things with me today and I
think I think it's about also setting
that that standard yourself but then
having lower expectations high standards
low expectations and what you're trying
to accomplish here set that that
standard set the positive example
and find a way to get there by in by by
having conversations not by dictating
rules yeah and there are there are also
activities you can do together that will
help each other live more in the moment
meaning you guys could could take a yoga
class together for a lot of people that
sounds silly
those people have probably not tried
yoga right because it is a very
meditative very relaxing experience you
could go for walks and take mindful
walks and leave the phones at home maybe
and and talk about the scenery and talk
about your day talk about the week ahead
it doesn't have to be perfect either if
you're gonna leave the phone at home and
try it once a week and ease into that
mindfulness you're not gonna become a
monk here overnight nor should that be
your objective a couple books I would
recommend I already mentioned Dan Harris
is 10% happier that's a good approach
beginner's approach toward a more
mindful life also Sam Harris he wrote a
book called waking up we did an
interview with Dan and interview with
Sam both about mindfulness you can find
those at the minimalists comm slash Dan
and the minimalists comm slash sam
respectively and you can find also on
there Sam has some good guided
meditations if you want to do a
meditation with your partner it's
something I've tried with with Becca
quite a bit we do meditations together
sometimes she gets mad at me though
because I I fall asleep about 50% of the
time when I'm meditating especially a
better day that night I'm like out like
a light and and so just realize that
there's probably a better time of day to
meditate I like to meditate in the
mornings because it keeps me from
falling asleep but if you meditate
together and try to do maybe some
breathing exercises together that's a
way to be much more mindful it's a way
to live in the moment all right our next
question is from Amy how did you find
your partners did you go looking for
them I don't go out to bars clubs
shopping etc and I found Moriah on
OkCupid which is a dating website I was
like when I met Mariah tinder was not
around so I have not tried the the
tinder app out at all app out at
I've heard a lot of mixed reviews on
that but whatever good friend met the
director of our film oh yeah that's
right he met his girlfriend yeah he met
his long-term girlfriend on on tender I
don't know if Matt wanted that to be
public but hey and that it is now sorry
not know but it's actually funny because
you know ten years ago if you were to
tell me that I was gonna meet my
significant other online I would have
been like how desperate am I gonna get
hmm
because that's kind of the stigma it had
like when the internet first came around
it was like this you know weird thing
that people would meet up online and now
it is I think it's the best way to to
meet people I went on probably 50
predates what were you calling them on
first date on first dates and and I
learned a lot from that it helped me to
really kind of take very deliberately
who I wanted to invest my time and
attention with and that's exactly the
reason why they're on there too um and
you know some people are on there for
different reasons but that's that's gets
pretty obvious pretty quickly on there
and you just these people yeah if you
are on a hook-up app just to have sex
with someone whatever and both people
decide that that's the route they want
to take that's fine just be safe be
responsible with that and and know what
you're getting into I think I think you
know you can have a lot of fun if you
want to do that yeah I think the point
I'm trying to make is that these sites
are usually kind of known for being
hookup apps but there they are the whole
it's the whole range you've got people
who are looking for lifelong partners to
have families with and settle down and
then you know you're looking at the
other side of the spectrum too so I
would definitely encourage you to do
that Amy if you haven't tried that route
at all and and you know I always joke
around with Mariah she will literally
the only date she went on from OkCupid
was with me here we are almost three
years later yeah where I'm like you have
no idea how lucky you are like you know
not just I have me obviously
no but but how lucky she was to not have
to go through all of those all of those
bad dates um I guess my time just yeah
I've got through a lot of bad online
dates I mean not even bad it's just you
realized very quickly that that okay we
don't have the similar interests we
don't have similar values we have very
different belief systems and that's okay
I met Becca the old-fashioned way or her
daughter was flirting with me at the
grocery store and Becca likes to say
that that ella has a has good taste in
men all right our last question is from
Melissa how and why this being a
minimalist improve our relationships you
know minimalism allows us to make room
for what's truly important and what's
truly important in my life my health and
the people around me and there are other
things that are important as well but
you know it's harder when you're
bringing minimalism into the lives of
other people but that's really what it
that's what makes minimalism worth it it
is a life of intention it is not a
perfect life it is not an easy life it
is a simple life okay now it's time to
move on to our added value portion of
the show this is where we each recommend
something that has added value to our
lives recently I'm gonna recommend two
things first a book by Cullen right it's
called some thoughts about relationships
and I'm not recommending this book
because I wrote the forward to the book
although I did write the foreword to the
book you could skip right past that I'm
recommending the book because it's the
book I have always asked Colin to write
I think Colin has a really unique view
on relationships a very non-judgmental
view and a very practical view but also
a non-traditional approach to both
traditional relationships and
non-traditional relationships and I
think it's phenomenal book in fact Bex
and I we sat down and read the entire
book chapter by chapter
over the course of about a week it's a
really short book I think it's as fewer
than a hundred pages but it is a great
book and he has all of these policies
that in the book so each chapter is a
different policy that he applies toward
his relationships and it has really
helped strengthen my relationship and it
has given me fodder for some phenomenal
deep conversations that I would not have
otherwise had and in my current
relationship and I don't think it's only
for intimate relationships I think these
are great conversations to have with
anyone you care about whether it's a
co-worker or it is a friend family
member etcetera the second thing I would
like to recommend is a television show
that I've really been enjoying lately
now I don't have a TV at home or the
Internet at home so I have to download
these these TV shows and I just go to
iTunes and download it but um the
grinder it's starring fellow de Tony and
Rob Lowe you know he was from Dayton
yeah he uh he and Fred Savage have this
hilarious show and they're like 21 then
it's an episode and the reason I
recommended it is if you just want to
veg out for 20 minutes or so Beck and I
will watch this at night yes sometimes
maybe once or twice a week and we'll
just crack up for 20 minutes and then
move on with our lives it's it's a it's
a great way to remove ourselves from the
realities of the world for a minute
laughs our butts off and then get back
into the real world together yeah I'm
going to recommend a Tony Robbins DVD
boxed set it's it's called the ultimate
relationship program and I know a lot of
people out there when they hear Tony
Robbins some people are like oh yeah
left Tony Robbins and other people are
like oh man he is way too exciting for
me I mean what I'll say is I started out
actually kind of looking at a Tony
Robbins stuff like man he is wait he is
way too hyper for me but once I actually
started listening to his advice and
listening to his words I found a lot a
lot of value in it and it's funny
because I almost didn't recommend this
today because it's like I'm looking at
it here on this sites 145 bucks
but it's cheaper than therapy right so
you know if you're someone who is in a
really really dire need and need to
change your perspective on relationships
this is a great DVD boxset that that
goes through just some amazing pointers
and and some ideas it's really it's
really perspective changing so if you
need to change your perspective look at
that gonna help you repair your
relationship or I found that it'll help
you seek better relationships in the
future as well so if you're in a
relationship that you need to try to to
repair or if you're looking for sort of
the ideal partner I think it's a great
way to start let's move on to our next
segment what we call right here right
now this is where we get to talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalists we have a few things going
on right now we're doing every Tuesday
in in February 2016 we are doing
Tuesdays with the minimalists on
periscope and Twitter at 7 p.m. Eastern
you can do a live ask the minimalists
session with us we spend half hour to an
hour answering your questions live on
periscope and Twitter find all the
details on that at the minimalists comm
slash Tuesdays we also have a
documentary coming out as you probably
know if you haven't seen the trailer for
that film yet it is phenomenal join the
hundreds of thousands of people who have
seen that trailer in the last week or so
you can go to minimalism film.com
and the trailer that is right there on
the main page and then if you want to
see the film it's coming out in theaters
May 24 2016 you just click on see the
film once you go to minimalism film calm
you'll see there are a couple hundred
screenings now I think are definitely
over 100 screenings at this point so in
a bunch of different cities you can buy
your tickets to a screening or if there
isn't a screening near you we could
certainly use your help you can request
the screening in your city or your
suburb or your small town wherever you
are and you can help us bring that to
your city it's really really easy we've
got all the information on
and if you want to see us in your city
we're actually going to 14 different
cities in May so we'll be all over the
place New York City and Washington DC
and Boston and Miami and doubtless and
Dayton Ohio and Toronto in Chicago and
Seattle and Los Angeles and San
Francisco and Salt Lake City and
Missoula and Fargo and I probably left
one or two out but you can see us on the
road those dates are selling out pretty
quickly but if you go to a date and it
has already sold out you can get put on
the waiting list we're looking for some
larger venues in some cities so so don't
worry you can find all of that under the
see the film tab at minimalism film.com
I'll mention minimalist or one more time
if you are looking for like-minded
people if you're looking for some
support if you've got friends and family
members who just want to give you the
respect that you deserve on your
minimalism journey you can go to one of
these groups and you can find someone
who who will support you and what I'll
say to that is just keep up the good
fight eventually your friends and family
will come around no matter what the
people who love you the people who care
about you the people who want you to be
happy they will eventually support you
so if you if you do need some support in
the meantime though go to minimalist org
and find your closest meetup group
finally here are some voicemail comments
from our last episode hi this is Audrey
I'm in Northern Virginia right now
listening to your podcast and I wanted
to leave a comment on your podcast
called stuff and I was kind of tearing
down I definitely used those two phrases
that you use the just in case and does
this add value now the just in case
didn't work as well for me because I
also like to hike in camp a lot so I
have them just in case as kind of
survival gear in a way first day things
like that but does this add value
instead of taking a strict inventory of
my things I just ask does this add value
and usually it ends up
in a donation bag or box that I take out
of my house was it full hi my name is
Mahal I'm calling from Baltimore
Maryland
I just want to convey a comment I don't
think you guys you guys have touched on
this before but I found that with
compulsive shopping one of the best ways
that I have been able to keep that at
bay is by picking out cash and I mean
looking at my list that I'm going out to
buy and then taking out enough cash to
cover that hi my name is Sylvia I live
in Denver Colorado and was just
listening to your podcast and one of the
strategies that I've used so this helps
me a lot in terms of that compulsive
buying that that one lady after that was
to not subscribe to like Groupon or
LivingSocial or Amazon local or things
like that because you get those emails
every morning and it looks like such an
amazing deal and it deals with video for
a little while and so to keep myself
from you know spending money that I
didn't need and then having a bunch of
Groupons but I never used I unsubscribe
for that it's made a pretty big impact
on me actually hey guys this is Kalman
from Milwaukee you too found a great
theme song but I was wondering - keenie
for some ill with one pie eat a verse
there's not many songs out there like it
and I think they did a really nice job
and I was just wondering if you the song
and if you haven't and wanted to give it
a listen your thoughts on it thanks
Kevin we definitely agree with you we
have found a phenomenal theme song that
theme song is by a very talented Irish
musician named Peter Doran you can find
out more about him at the minimalists
comm slash peter and yes we love the
aether brothers I've seen them perform
live I saw them open for fellow Montanan
John Mayer a couple years ago and they
are phenomenal so we'll close out this
episode at the very end here with that
song from The Avett Brothers and that's
really all we have for this episode if
you have a question for the minimalists
give us a call 406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 and if
you leave here with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
and a little scene that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine without me
[Music]
sort in your
[Music]
you
you
[Music]